Leatherface had cut down the old man in  a strange outfit maybe now that he was  dead  the pretty yellow haired gum-chewing  girl would notice Leatherface putting on  his fanciest mask  Leatherface found the army camp with a  pretty girl could be found most days he  had to cut through a few guards and more  than a few of her friends to get to her  but it was worth it he pulled out the  old man's face which he'd saved for the  girl as a present  the girl didn't want the present and she  wasn't being nice  so Leatherface trapped her into tiny  pieces for greatly to use in his chili  he then took off his mask and set to  work on the girl's face if she wasn't  going to be his girlfriend she could be  his in other ways  you